what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with the power rangers at last
i know it's been a little while
kind of had a lot going on behind the
scenes so i do apologize for this taking
us a while to get back to it but this is
actually a really really good segment
right so this kind of takes place
between the last video that we did and
and really the next one but it's kind of
out of time right what this does is it
basically tells us how it is exactly
that the green ranger was able to
conquer the world and more so than that
why it is that the sword of saba right
which belongs to the white ranger why it
is that it was just sitting under the
command center and why tommy never
really seemed to get his hands on it
because that was kind of the big
question that a lot of us had i noticed
a lot of you guys had that question in
the comments which was like how could
tommy not find that thing right i mean
how is it possible that it just hit
itself away what this does is it
initially picks up with the opening of
the portal and everything popping off
with lord drakken and all that stuff and
zordon as we knew him in the main power
rangers universe was really believed to
have been dead the reality is that he
wasn't instead he was basically yanked
out of the main power rangers universe
and kind of sent to a place between
dimensions right between the main power
rangers universe and the universe where
that alternate reality green ranger had
basically conquered everything and so
again we can kind of use this proper
name and call him lord drakken that's
really what his name is uh but the
reality of this is as he kind of goes
through it is in a lot of ways looking
at a mirror do you guys remember that
scene in inception when matthew
mcconaughey is just kind of floating in
the black hole and he's looking at his
past right through like the bookshelf
and that kind of stuff that's really
what this is right it's almost like
looking in this window kind of peeking
through this window into this house that
is this alternate reality and one of the
things we're told here is that in this
alternate reality this alternate zordon
even with the the the power of rita
repulsa seemingly been defeated insofar
as like the sword of darkness was
destroyed and her hold over that
alternate reality tommy should have more
or less ended in the same way it did in
the main power rangers universe instead
unlike the main power rangers universe
that version of tommy stayed with rita
repulsa so at this point it wasn't even
that he was under her control it seemed
as though it was just a choice he made
that he believed in the idea of rita
repulsa now again a lot of this is
predicated on the world as it exists and
that's one of the great things about
power rangers is that yes it very it is
very easy for us to kind of get caught
up in the fantasy that like if given the
opportunity everybody will always make
the right choice the reason why people
make bad choices is because they don't
have the wherewithal or they don't have
the opportunity to make good choices but
the reality is that even in the face of
having the opportunity to make good
choices people still make bad choices
because people are people
because sometimes we just want to do bad
things or sometimes we're just
inherently bad people and that's one of
the great things about power rangers is
that there is very much a tangible
element to this story and it's the thing
the power rangers don't really seem to
understand is why is tommy still allied
with rita repulsa if we destroy the
sword of darkness and her spell over
tommy has basically been relinquished
right so tommy is operating of his own
accord and zordon really seems to ignore
the reality of the truth which is that
tommy chooses to stay with rita instead
it's what her influence over him must
still be strong right zordon you know
whether you love him or hate him zordon
has always had this almost kind of
naivety in terms of how he viewed the
world in the sense that there's always
good in people and they can always make
good choices uh that's not always true
that this alternate reality version of
tommy legitimately just seemed to have
been a bad guy and it's one of the
things that the main power rangers
universe zord on as he's watching his
alternate reality counterpart talk it's
one of the things that he kind of hits
on right he's like even as i hear my
other self speak these words the time
stream shifts and i bear witness to how
wrong he seems to have been that this
version of tommy oliver was never a
person worth believing in in the first
place and that's kind of an interesting
thing is because we're sort of given
this almost juxtaposition between these
two versions of tommy oliver right the
green ranger that in the main power
rangers universe the green ranger was a
guy who was kind of a loner he was sort
of doing his own thing living in
isolation wanting to be left alone and
then was basically you know press ganged
into working alongside rita repulsa
after he was hoodwinked but as soon as
the sword of darkness was destroyed her
influence over him diminished that the
power rangers approached him as friends
and while i wouldn't go as far as to say
that there was like this okay cool you
guys are the best thing ever that at the
very least a loose alliance was formed
when ultimately tommy sided with the
power rangers against rita repulsa which
led to her defeat in this reality that
never happened instead much like what
we've seen and really kind of been
hinted on in previous videos that tommy
chose to stay with rita and he basically
helped her conquer the world that it
started in washington dc and then it
spread out to all these major capitals
and the reality was all humanity could
really do was run and high that it was
really left to the power rangers to face
off against the forces of rita and do
what they could now they did find allies
where they could in terms of defeating
you know tommy and rita and even so far
he's reaching out to ninja now for those
of you guys who are unfamiliar with who
ninja is ninja was the tv show
equivalent of them getting ninja powers
in the movie right you guys remember in
the the original power rangers movie
with like ivan oohs and all that kind of
stuff and they became like ninjas and so
on and so forth the movie is not
necessarily in continuity i guess some
elements of it are but the movie itself
is not and so what they needed was a way
to basically have the power rangers gain
ninja powers because it was just so
incredibly popular at the time it
couldn't be ignored it was 1990s and if
you're a little kid ninjas were the
coolest thing ever but ultimately they
were like we need this so ninja was
created in the series as a way to give
the power rangers basically ninja
abilities right to make him look
something akin to like ninja rangers and
so that's why ninja is here because he
alongside the reinforcements that you
see here have been long-standing allies
with the power rangers and all of them
unified their forces and tried to face
off against tommy and uh and rita and
ultimately as we know it didn't work now
one of the funny things here is that it
was believed when we originally got the
backstory of lord draken without all
this revelation here that that the the
the red ranger jason was believed to
have been killed in reality that doesn't
seem to be the case he was defeated but
at the end of the day tommy when he had
stolen the power of the white ranger and
merged it with his power of the green
ranger to become lord drakken he issued
an ultimatum to zordon right to that
alternate reality zordon and said i will
give you one last shot to basically ally
yourself with me and the forces of rita
repulsa if you do not we will destroy
you right he already says he chronically
poisoned him so in essence he's more or
less dying right i mean there really is
no way to stop that because in reality
as long as zordon is alive he will
always stand as a resistance to rita
repulsa and to lord drakken right that's
his charter his charter is to keep the
world or keep the really the universe
itself safe and free as best as he
possibly can you are really focusing
largely on earth and so he would always
try to find new power rangers more
powerful rangers he would try to develop
new and more capable technologies but he
would always stand as a leader of the
resistance what tommy oliver is offering
here is not to save the life of this
ultimate reality zordon but he's
basically saying like you are dying so
if you do not ally yourself with us
right if you don't pledge your
allegiance then i will basically detach
you from space and time from this
location that you're in and you will die
in an endless void alone there will not
be any hope for you and so where you end
up having him just resist tommy and say
that's not gonna happen tommy does
exactly what he said he did and he would
just he detached him from that reality
and sent him into the kind of void of
space now this is when this alternate
reality zordon who we'll call zordon 2
ends up meeting the main power rangers
universe zordon who we'll call zordon 1.
and zordon 1 kind of looks to this
alternate reality version while he looks
at zordon 2 and he's just kind of like
how could you possibly have believed in
tommy oliver i've been watching things
unfold in your universe how could you
possibly be so naive as to believe that
even in the face of everything that's
happened that tommy can somehow be
redeemed because as the two of them are
talking literally the windows to this
alternate reality are open and it's just
lord drakken just just laying waste to
everyone the power rangers are fighting
valiantly they're fighting as is with as
much effort as they possibly can but at
the end of the day it's not enough
they're just falling one after another
right the reinforcements are falling one
after another this this army of putties
numbering seemingly in the hundreds of
thousands if not possibly the millions
are just it's literally a war of
attrition that as capable as the power
rangers are they can't fight forever
between this the massive monsters that
rita repulsa has there's no real way for
the rangers to face off against this and
to actually be successful and so
literally while this conversation is
going on they're watching all these
power rangers die and so ultimately
zordon 1 asks zordon 2 in the face of
all this do you wish to give a final
account and zordon 2 says no only that i
don't regret any of the decisions that
i've made and that's when zordon one's
like really man like look at this dude
you could have just instructed your
power rangers do what you gotta do kill
tommy oliver if you have to right it
sucks that we have to but hey sometimes
guys can't be redeemed and the only way
to to fix things is to just eliminate
them you could have instructed them to
do that but nonetheless zordon 2 holds
strong and says no right things may not
always go the way in which we desire but
i believe there will be enough good
people making enough good decisions that
good will ultimately triumph over evil
even if it is not in the way that we
initially think and he says for example
everything that has happened in my world
has brought you here and now one day it
will bring others right basically kind
of what we talked about at the beginning
of the shadow grid story when billy and
tommy from the main power rangers
universe were thrown into this alternate
reality where lord drakken and rita
repulse had conquered everything right
so again a little this story takes place
as kind of a flashback but he basically
says trust in your rangers zordon trust
true to your beliefs like hold on to
that you know they are noble and they
make us who we are and it's kind of a
funny thing here because even though
this guy appears to be wildly naive it
also looks like he's kind of looking at
the bigger picture right where he's like
in this moment right now yes right lord
lord drakken has basically killed my
rangers uh he has laid waste to to earth
right to this to this reality's earth uh
and they have effectively conquered it
but so long as there is good out there
this is simply one battle in what is a
massive war and that when the dust
settles and when it's all said and done
lord drakken will have long since been
defeated and the forces of evil will
have basically been kept at bay and the
forces of good will have prevailed but
again it doesn't work that way that evil
is just a constant thing that exists
it's one of the things that power
rangers series gave us right like we're
just new threats are constantly
appearing the universe is a big place
and there's a lot of folks out there
even from other dimensions who are
constantly looking to seize the day and
to take control of everything for any
number of reasons and so again evil will
never truly be defeated but the message
being delivered here is that in this
particular conflict in this particular
war yes my reality is essentially lost
right yes lord drakken has been defeated
but everything that has transpired has
led to you and your rangers becoming
aware of this and then coming to this
alternate reality so even if my rangers
are unable to defeat lord drakken yours
potentially are so your rangers can save
my universe it's really philosophically
intriguing right and so what zordon 1
says is he watches his alternate reality
counterpart basically fade away and
essentially die as he says whether it
was bearing witness to my own death or
bearing witness to what happened in this
alternate world in that moment i truly
felt myself becoming lost the portal
effects that allowed me to view this
other timeline began to fade and so too
did i and then suddenly he's basically
met by the arrival of saba now this is
not truly saba in terms of like the
actual sword it's more or less kind of
like morphine form right a spiritual
form you know if you really want to call
it that and as he meets with this
version of zordon he's like okay you're
not the zordon that i know you're not
the zordon for my reality but you are a
zordon what do you think that we should
do here and ultimately this version of
zordon almost kind of looked at that and
says okay so like your version of tommy
oliver yeah he was an evil guy my tommy
oliver i believe ki is a good guy right
because the the main power rangers tommy
oliver has demonstrated that right he's
shown that he hasn't quite gone down
this exact same path he hasn't betrayed
the rangers despite being removed from
the influence of rita repulsa instead
when that influence was removed he
turned against rita and he allied
himself with the rangers so he's like
he'll basically help us in any way that
he can and so ultimately when this
message is communicated to saba that's
the reason why the sword basically took
off from lord drakken and then when
zack's like where are you going the
response to saba was give it time right
in time i will return i am not
abandoning you i am i am i'm going to a
place that's safe where lord drakken can
never find me and a time will come when
new power rangers will emerge into this
universe and when they arrive i will
bring them with me and your job is to
help us defeat lord drakken during that
time zack basically started marshaling
forces right the coinless like those
individuals out there who don't have you
know traditional power rangers abilities
who are basically a ragtag resistance
force trying to defeat lord drakken as
best as they possibly can this is why
zach in this alternate reality start
assembling all these different
resistance maneuvers and groups and so
on and so ultimately this is the reason
why when tommy oliver from the main
power rangers universe and billy from
the main power rangers universe ended up
in this alternate reality that sabah
didn't immediately turn against that
version of tommy and say you are
responsible for this and like attack him
right because he'd basically been told
by zordon tommy from my universe is
going to come here along with another
guy and when they get here i believe in
that version of tommy and that version
of tommy will save us from your version
of tommy so that's why he ultimately
ended up allying with saba but with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
to an end i gotta say man power rangers
is killer it's just it's a ridiculously
amazing comic let me know what you guys
think down in the comments section and i
will catch you all later
peace